- Oh, don't tell me you
broke another light bulb.
- Nope, I'm just putting
in an energy efficient LED.
- But wait, aren't those more expensive?
- Yes, but going green can save you money.
- Wait, so, it costs
more and saves you money?
- Yup.
(upbeat music)
(whooshing sound)
Going green, we've all heard about it,
but what does it actually mean?
Simply put, it's
protecting the environment
from harm and conserving
natural resources.
These days, there are
lots of ways to do it.
You can bike instead of drive.
Eat organic, switch to
solar energy and so on.
But this isn't new.
In fact, saving energy has been around
for thousands of years.
- Egypt used to take
old letters and use them
for money wrappings to save on papyri.
British activists during
the Industrial Revolution,
successfully protested the construction
of railways that would
have ruined the land.
There are many examples throughout history
of people protecting the environment,
whether they realized it or not.
- And it wasn't until 1962
that the environmental
movement really took off,
with the release of Rachel
Carson's "Silent Spring".
This book informed the
world about pesticides
that could cause cancer
and threaten wildlife.
This led to the formation
of the Environmental Protection Agency
and help inspire the very first Earth Day,
where 20 million people across America,
protested environmental destruction.
- Since the 1970s, awareness
of environmental issues
has grown, along with
information and resources
helping people go green.
Thankfully, some ways you
can reduce energy costs
nothing at all, like
recycling or turning off
the lights when you're not using them.
But you may have also
noticed that many products
and solutions that help us
go green cost more money
than there are less environmentally
friendly competitors.
What's up with that?
- Well, sometimes the
product itself costs more
to make, that's the
case with organic food,
which reduces pollution but
also requires more labor
to produce.
But that's not always the
case with green products.
Some charge more because, well, they can.
Eco-friendly is
unfortunately sometimes used
as a marketing strategy to
appeal to wealthier shoppers.
- But even with this
increased cost upfront,
going green can still save
you money in the long run.
- How much exactly?
I think it's time to...
- [Both] Run the numbers!
(orchestral music)
- This is Sam.
She's not the most
environmentally conscious person.
In fact, the thought of saving energy
never even crosses her mind.
But one day Sam comes across a Ted talk
that gets her really fired
up to save the planet.
How much money will she save?
Let's look at some examples.
And heads up, there's a
lot of numbers this time.
So, math nerds, you're welcome.
- Okay, so currently Sam uses 75 watt
incandescent light bulbs
for five hours a day.
She has 40 of them in her
home and they cost $1 each.
If she switches all 40 of
these bulbs to 11 watt LEDs
which costs $5 each, she has
to pay $160 more upfront.
But because LEDs use less energy,
she'll save about $600 a year.
That comes out to around $50 a month.
So, in just over three
months, she'll make back
the initial $160 she
lost, pretty sweet deal.
- Now let's see how much Sam will save
by switching shower heads.
Currently, she uses one that pumps out
two and a half gallons
of water per minute.
If she buys a low flow shower head,
it only use a gallon
and a half per minute.
Let's say she takes seven
minute showers for 25 days
out of the month and uses
an electric water heater.
With her previous shower
head that comes out
to 438 gallons of water compared to 263
with her new one, pretty
impressive water savings.
So, it must save a lot
of money too, right?
- Not exactly.
This upgrade would only
save her $2 a month.
- Which isn't a lot but
she could put those savings
towards a good cause like, I don't know,
supporting Two Cents on Patriot.
- Not now, babe.
- Sorry.
- Okay, so, what if Sam
switches to an electric car?
I mean, General Motors just announced
they're switching all their
cars to electric by 2035,
so, why not Sam?
After all, she doesn't drive
the best car for the planet,
a 2010 Honda Accord.
So, if she drives the
average number of miles,
paying $2.50 a gallon,
she'll be looking at over
$1,300 a year in gas alone.
But if she buys a 2021
Nissan Leaf electric car,
she'll pay just over
$500 a year to charge it,
that's over $800 a year in savings.
- And while some electric
cars cost a fortune
and can be more in insurance,
a new Nissan Leaf is only around $31,000
and offers insurance
rates that are comparable
to many gas powered cars.
Sam could also get the
federal tax incentive
knocking down the price even further.
Plus, electric vehicles
cost thousands less
in maintenance and repairs
over their lifetime.
So, she could potentially save
around $300 a year on these costs alone.
- If Sam's not ready to
ditch her Honda, though,
she could still save money
by biking to work instead of driving,
and she'll get in her daily exercise too.
So, let's assume Sam is closer to work
than the average American
and it's 10 miles each way.
That's 100 a week or 400 miles a month,
she's not driving in her car.
After factoring in operating
costs and maintenance,
the bike costs about $6
a month to ride to work,
compared to around $53 a month
if she would have driven.
That means Sam saves about
$47 a month by biking to work
which is over $550 a year.
So, if her bike costs her $500,
she'll make that up and
savings in just under a year.
And she might even get
a lower insurance rate
by driving less.
Some insurance companies
offer 20% off or more
once you get below a
certain number of miles.
Others offer smaller
discount or not at all,
it depends on company
demographics and in some cases
if you're willing to put
a tracker in your car.
- And if Sam really wants to go all out,
she could get a solar panel.
These generate their
own power from the sun
reducing electricity
costs by as much as 100%.
Admittedly, it's a bit pricey.
For a five kilowatt system,
it could cost her $20,000,
but she should be able
to get a 22% federal tax incentive,
knocking off nearly $4,500.
On top of that, she might
qualify for local rebates
and incentives.
So, now let's say we're
looking at $12,000.
If the solar panels saves
her $100 a month on energy,
this will pay itself off in 10 years.
Then she'll have little to no energy costs
for the remaining 15 years
of the system's life,
how cool is that?
- So as you can see, sometimes going green
will save you a lot ,of money,
other times, not so much.
And in some cases you'll
save nothing at all.
Like if you recycle or eat organic food.
So, why do it when it's not
financially beneficial to you?
- Because the truth is,
the environmental situation
is in critical condition.
Climate change is causing
extreme weather events
like the snowpocalypse
we endured here in Texas
a couple months ago,
which could end up having
a $200 billion economic impact.
Hundreds of thousands of people die
from air pollution every year.
And over 500 species of land
animals are on the brink
of extinction because of the
human destruction of nature.
- These issues affect all of us.
And while it's great that in so many cases
you'll end up paying less by going green,
that's not the only
reason to make the change.
- Doing our part to fight climate change
and protect the planet
is worth doing regardless
of the personal savings.
- [Both] And that's our two cents.
- Our PBS friends across YouTube
are celebrating Earth Day.
Follow me over to Weathered on Terra
to learn more about the rise in floods
in the age of climate change,
and what you can do to prepare.
Tell them Two Cents sent you.
- One more thing, for
those of you in the US,
you should check out Greta Thunberg,
A Year to Change the World,
a new three hour earth day broadcast event
on your local PBS station.
The special is going to
premiere on Thursday, April 22nd
at 8/7 Central and will then
repeat starting Wednesday,
April 28th at 8/7 Central.
- Thanks to our
patrons for keeping Two Cents
financially healthy.
Click the link in the
description to become
a Two Cents patron.
(upbeat music)